all right let's talk a little bit more
about the vaccines you know i said to
you a few weeks ago i don't want to talk
about covid that much anymore because in
many ways it's more a virus of the mind
at this point if you've decided to go
about living your life how you see fit
and get vaccinated if you want to or not
if you don't and you take into account
your your doctor's feelings and all of
that stuff it's like we need to move
forward we're two years in already it's
like it's time to move on however
because they keep coming at us with more
crazy mandates and now more uh atta i
would say a tax that is the right word a
tax on children it's like we got to talk
about it to some degree so
uh in the last day or so the fda has
voted 17 to zero to start okaying
vaccinations for children five to eleven
years old well now some video leaked uh
this is the editor of the new england
journal of medicine his name is dr eric
rubin and i am in no way related to dr
eric rubin i want to make that very
clear i am also in no way related to
jennifer rubin the washington post
columnist these are rubens that have
nothing to do
with me
i am not related to dr eric rubin i am
not related to jennifer rubin anyway dr
eric rubin is one of the 17 people on
the fda panel and they were talking
about vaccinations for children and this
video just leaked and if you don't think
this is mind-blowingly extraordinary i
don't know what to tell you this is nuts
but we're never going to learn about how
facebook vaccine is unless we start
giving it yeah that's just the way it
goes
we're never going to learn about how
safe the vaccine is unless we're giving
it
he's talking about two children
two children now i want to be clear
there were a couple clinical studies for
kids that were very very rushed through
but that man is one of the 17 people
on the board that is deciding whether
your children five years old are going
to be injected with this stuff i'm not
saying anything bad is going to happen
if they're injected i don't know but
either do they so i'm saying leave it up
to you but these are the people who are
going to want to make sure that if you
send your kid to school or if you send
your kid to the freaking roller skating
rink do they still have roller skating
rinks is that still a thing or bowling
are kids allowed to bowl anymore
like
that they're going to demand that your
kid gets vaccinated so this is
absolutely crazy they are admitting we
do not know what will happen until we
inject this stuff into your kids that
was shown i believe live on c-span are
you seeing that on cnn today are you
seeing that on that clown network msnbc
absolutely crazy and it's just such a
long string of misinformation that these
people tell us you might remember this
video this is from joe biden's town hall
not the one he did a couple days ago
with uh anderson cooper where he just
muddled and befuddled his way through
the whole thing and yammered and
stammered and
it was horrible this is from a couple
months ago and listen to what joe says
about the vaccines and you tell me is it
true or not
the the various
shots that people are getting now cover
that they're they're you're okay you're
not gonna you're not gonna get covet if
you have these vaccinations
well hot damn you're not gonna get covet
if you have these vaccinations that
either was 100 of a lie by the man
pretending to be president of the united
states or the vaccines are not working
as promised you may remember this guy
dave rubin who back in july tweeted out
that vaccine mandates are coming and the
vaccines are not working as promised
that dave rubin guy real right wing nut
bag he got banned from twitter for
saying that then i was able to get
enough public outcry on that that they
admitted that it was an error yeah just
an error uh but yeah that's uh that's
interesting so let me get this straight
we're going to have to test on the kids
to see what's going on here that's
coming from one of the doctors on the
fda board now you've got the president a
couple of months ago saying yeah if you
get vaccinated you're okay but we know
that not only are people still getting
coveted if they're vaccinated but
they're still transmitting kovid if
they're vaccinated but now some fairly
well-known influential doctors are
finally stepping up and saying this
stuff related to the kids cannot go on
we've got a tweet here from dr aaron
caharidy he is a professor of psychiatry
and director of medical ethics at uc
irvine he said let the record show i am
convinced that today's decision by the
fda to give eua authorization for five
to eleven-year-old children for the
pfizer vaccine will be seen as one of
the worst medical disasters of the 21st
century say what you want in response
and we'll check back in 20 years okay so
i know that some doctors will be for
this and i know that some doctors will
be against it but the point is there is
something to debate do you not think
there is something to debate while 17
board members
are at the fda are saying go ahead and
just inject it into the kids and then
we'll see what happens that's what
they're saying they are literally if you
have a child that's five to 11 years old
right now i said to david this morning
we don't have kids yet and in a weird
way as badly as we want kids and we are
trying and it's been very complex
possibly because of uh vaccines related
to surrogates and everything else it's
like
in a twisted way i feel almost blessed
that we don't have kids yet because what
a horrific decision you would have to
make if you have a five-year-old right
now and they're saying your kid's not
gonna be able to go to school your kid's
not gonna be able to participate in
society and then you watch a video that
you're not gonna see on mainstream news
and you've got the doctor going but we
don't know what it's gonna do kids
and then you gotta run around and tell
all your friends that and the teachers
and the administrators they're going to
go oh you're a right-wing q maniac
you're watching too much alex jones i
mean this is what they have done to
society and until you really realize
that like realize it and then you can
empower yourself on how you fight these
people
and and that may mean you have to leave
where you live you may have to get to a
state that is more associated uh with
the beliefs that you have that is really
the position that we are at right now
but that lunatic reuben okay that
lunatic ruben like i would not be
trusting that guy to be injecting
anything into my children while he's
saying he doesn't know what will happen
until we do it and then we'll see you
know sure
you know they're going to get big eye
everyone's gonna be walking around one
big guy one little eye
but i don't know we'll have to see
ridiculous